room stratford hotel on the historic
greenwood avenue was sat
and burned to the ground during the
tulsa race massacre of 1921
along with over 30 square blocks of
black owned property
causing him to flee to kansas and later
to chicago
to save his own life
he was falsely indicted for inciting the
riot
by an inflamed white grand jury
for daring to stand up with his
community
to stop a mob from breaking into the
jail
and lynching a black teenager named dick
roman
sparking the backlash which ended in the
grievous massacre
my family worked to get these charges
against jb
dropped posthumously
i know how lucky i am to have this
family history
passed down from generation to
generation
this history was the one thing that they
were not able
to steal from us but as thankful as i am
to know my history i understand that
history
has no firm line to divide it from the
present
just as there are survivors still with
us today
from this tragic event the mentality of
the mob
to declare that there would never again
be another
black wall street in tulsa that
mentality
also still survives in many institutions
and unfortunately in many people's
hearts
today we welcome president joe biden
here
to stand beside us as we continue the
fight
for justice for the survivors and
descendants
of the tulsa massacre he understands
that as a nation we are and we
must be strong enough to confront
the dark periods of our history with a
bold agenda
of equity repair and healing
jb stratfor died without seeing justice
for the crimes against him in his
community
but i am sure we will see justice in my
lifetime
thanks to the efforts of all of you here
joining us today
and now i introduce to you
president joe biden
[Applause]
thank you please if you have a seat sit
down
and i gotta make one check
i just had to make sure the two girls
got ice cream and this is over
imagine how excited you'd be when you're
four
five almost five years old coming to
hear
a president speak my lord
my faith we call that purgatory
lauren thank you for that gracious
introduction
and in case you're wondering i
in delaware we're a small state
we have the eighth largest black
population in america
and we have one of the most talented
members of congress
and so if i didn't walk around and pay
my tribute to
lisa blunt rochester my congressman
immediately
how are you rev good to see you
i we've got a distinguished group of
people here
and uh and i want to thank lauren for
sharing
the powerful story uh and for helping uh
the country understand what's happening
here
and to all the descendants here today
and to the community and
civil rights leaders and members of the
congressional black caucus that are here
thank you for making sure we all
remember
that we never forget you know there's a
verse in
first corinthians that says for now
we see in a mirror dimly but then
face to face now i know in part
then i shall know fully
it is i just uh toured the hall of
survivors
here in greenwood cultural center and i
want to thank the incredible staff for
hosting us here
and if i didn't say what my father and
sister would please accuse my back
but the tour in the tour i met mother
randall
who's only uh 56 years old
god lover and mother fletcher who's uh
67 years old and her brother
her brother van ellis who's 100 years
old
and he looks like he's 60. thank you for
spending so much time with me
i really mean it it was a great honor a
genuine honor
you are the three known remaining
survivors
of a story seen in the mirror dimly
but no longer now your story
will be known in full view the events
we speak of today took place 100 years
ago
and yet i'm the first president in 100
years ever to come to tulsa
i say that not as a compliment about me
but to think about it a hundred years
and the first president to be here
during that entire time and in this
place
in this ground to acknowledge the truth
what took place here for much too long
the history of what took place here was
told in silence
cloaked in darkness but just because
history is silent
it doesn't mean that it did not take
place
and while darkness can hide much it
erases
nothing it erases nothing
some injustices are so heinous so
horrific so grievous
they can't be buried no matter how hard
people try
and so it is here only only with truth
can come healing injustice and repair
only with truth facing it but that
isn't enough first we have to see
hear and give respect
to mother randall mother fletcher and mr
van ellis
and all those lost
so many years ago to all the descendants
of those who suffered
to this community that's why we're here
to shine a light to make sure america
knows the story in full
may 1921
formerly enslaved black people and their
descendants are here in tulsa
a boom town of oil and opportunity and a
new frontier
on the north side across the rail tracks
that divided the city already segregated
by law
they built something of their own
worthy worthy of their talent and their
ambition
greenwood a community a way of life
black doctors and lawyers pastors
teachers
running hospitals law practices
libraries churches
schools black veterans
like the man i had the privilege of
giving a command coin to
who fought volunteered and fought and
came home and still
faced such prejudice
veterans have been back a few years
helping
after win the first world war building a
new life back home with pride and
confidence
who were a mom and there were at the
time mom
and plaque mom and and pop black diners
grocery stores barber shops tailors the
things that make up a community
at the dreamland theater a young black
couple holding hands falling in love
friends gathered at music clubs and pool
halls
at the monroe family roller skating rink
visitors staying at hotels like the
stratford
all around black pride shared by the
professional class
and the working class who live together
side by side
for blocks on end
mother randall was just six years old
six years old
living with her grandma she said she was
lucky to have a home and toys
and fortunate to live without fear
mother fletcher was seven years old
second of seven children
the youngest being mr van ellis
was just a few months old the children
former sharecroppers when they went to
bed at night in greenwood mother
fletcher says
they fell asleep rich in terms of the
wealth
not real wealth but a different wealth a
wealth in culture
and community and heritage
but one night one night
changed everything everything changed
while green was a was a community to
itself
it was not separated from the outside
it wasn't everyone but there was enough
hate resent resentment and vengeance in
the community
enough people who believed that america
does not belong to everyone
and not everyone is created equal
native americans asian americans
hispanic americans black americans
a belief enforced by law
by badge by hood and by noose
that speaks to that
lit the fuse it lit it by the spark that
it provided
a fuse a fury
was an innocent interaction that turned
into an
ins in a terrible terrible headline
allegation
of a black male teenager attacking a
white female teenager
a white mob of a thousand
gathered around the courthouse where the
black teenagers being held
ready to do it still occurred lynch
that young man that night but 75
black men including black veterans
arrived to stand guard
wards were exchanged then a scuffle
then a shots fired hell was unleashed
literal hell was unleashed through the
night
and in the morning the mob terrorized
green with torches
and guns shooting at will a mob
tied a black man by the waist to the
back of their truck
with his head banging along the pavement
as they drove off
a murder black family draped over the
fence of their home
outside an elderly couple knelt by their
bed praying to god
with their heart and their soul when
they were shot
in the back of their heads private
planes
private planes dropping explosives
the first and only domestic aerosol of
its kind
on an american city here in tulsa
eight of greenwood's nearly two dozen
churches burned like
mount zion across the street at burn an
ame
mother randall said it was like a war
mother fletcher says all these years
later she
still sees black bodies around
the greenwood newspaper publisher aj
smitherton
assuming smitherman penned a poem
of what he heard and felt that night
and here's the poem he said kill them
burn them
set the pace teach them how to keep
their place
reign of murder theft and plunder was
the order of the night
that's what he remembers in the poem
that he wrote
100 years ago at this hour
on this first day of june smoke
darkened the tulsa sky
rising from 35 blocks of greenwood
they were left in ash and ember raised
in rubble
less than 24 hours less than 24 hours
1 100 black homes and businesses were
lost
insurance companies they had insurance
many of them
rejected claims of damage
10 000 people were left destitute and
homeless
placing internment camps as i was told
today
they were told don't you mention you
were ever in a camp
we'll come and get you that's a survivor
storm
yet no one no arrests
of the mob were made none
no proper accounting of the dead
the death toll records by local
officials said there were
36 people that's all
36 people based on studies
records and accounts the likelihood
the likely number is much more in the
multiple of hundreds
untold bodies dumped into mass graves
families who at a time waited for
hours and days to know the fate of their
loved ones
are now descendants
who have gone 100 years without cloture
but you know as we speak
the process the process of exhuming
the unmarked graves has started
and at this moment i'd like to pause
for a moment of silence for the fathers
the mothers the sisters sons and
daughters
friends of god and greenwood
they deserve the dignity and they
deserve our respect
may their souls rest in peace
my fellow americans this was not a ride
this was a massacre
[Applause]
among among the worst in our history
but not the only one
and for too long forgotten by our
history
as soon as it happened there was a clear
effort
to erase it from our memory our
collective memories
from the news and everyday conversations
for a long time schools in tulsa didn't
even teach it
let alone schools elsewhere and most
people didn't realize that a century ago
the second ku klux klan had been founded
the second ku klux kennedy founded a
friend of mine john meacham
i'd written when i said i was running to
restore the soul of america
he wrote a book called the soul of
america not because of what i said
there's a picture about page 160 in the
book
showing over 30 000 ku klux klan members
in full regalia reverend pointed hats
the robes
marching down pennsylvania avenue in
washington d.c jesse you know all about
this
washington washington dc if my memory is
correct there were
37 members of the house of
representatives who were open members of
the clan
there were five if i'm not mistaken
could have been seven i think it was
five
members of the united states senate open
members of the klan
multiple governors were open
members of the klan
most people didn't realize that a
century ago that klan
was founded just six years before the
horrific destruction here in tulsa
and one of the reasons why it was
founded
was because the guys like me are
catholic
it wasn't about african-americans then
it was about making sure that all those
polish
and irish and italian and eastern
european catholics who came to the
united states after world war one
would not pollute christianity
the flames from those burning crosses
towards every region every region of the
country
millions of white americans belong to
the clan
and they weren't even embarrassed by it
they were proud of it
and that hate became embedded
systematically and systemically in our
laws and our culture
we do ourselves no favors by pretending
none of this
ever happened or doesn't impact us today
because it does still impact us today
we can't just choose to learn what we
want to know
and not what we should know
we should know the good
the bad everything
that's what great nations do they come
to
terms
with their dark sides and we're a great
nation
the only way to build a common ground is
to truly repair and to rebuild
i come here to help fill the silence
because in silence wounds deepen
and only as painful as it is only in
remembrance
do wounds heal we just have to choose to
remember
we memorialize what happened here in
tulsa so it can be
so it can't be erased we know here
in this hallowed place we simply can't
bury
pain and trauma forever and at some
point
will be a reckoning an inflection point
like we're facing right now as a nation
what many people hadn't seen before or
har are
simply refused to see cannot be ignored
any
longer you see it in so many places
there's greater recognition that for too
long
we've allowed a narrowed cramped view
of the promise of this nation to fester
the view that america is a zero-sum game
where there's only one winner if you
succeed
i fail if you get ahead
i'm fall behind if you get a job
i lose mine and maybe worst of all
if i hold you down i lift myself
up
instead of if you do well we all do well
we see that in greenwood
this story isn't about the loss of life
but a loss of living of wealth and
posterity and possibilities
that still reverb race today mother
fletcher talks about how she was the
only able to attend school in the fourth
grade
and eventually found work in the
shipyards as a domestic worker
mr van ellis has shared how even after
enlisting and serving in world war
ii he still came home to struggle with a
segregated america
imagine all those hotels and dinners and
mom and pop shops
that could have been passed down this
past hundred years
imagine what could have been done for
black families in greenwood
financial security and generational
wealth
if you come from backlines like my my
family working class middle-class
families
the only way we ever able to generate
any wealth
is inequity in our homes imagine what
they contributed then
what they could have contributed all
these years
imagine a thriving greenwood in north
tulsa for the last hundred years
but that would have meant for all of
tulsa including the white community
while the people of green would rebuilt
again in the years after the massacre
it didn't last eventually neighborhoods
were redlined on maps
locking black tulsa out of home
ownerships
a highway was built right through the
heart of the community
he said i was talking about our west
side what 95 did
after we were occupied by the military
after dr king was
murdered the community cutting off black
families and businesses from jobs and
opportunity
chronic underinvestment from state and
federal governments denied greenwood
even just a chance of rebuilding
we must find the courage to change the
things we know we can change
that's what vice president harris and i
are focused on
along with our entire administration
including our housing urban development
secretary
marcia fudge who is here today
[Applause]
because today we're announcing two
expanded efforts
targeted toward black wealth creation
that will also help
the entire community the first is my
administration has launched an
aggressive effort to combat racial
discrimination and housing
that includes everything from redlining
to the cruel fact that a home owned by a
black family
is too often appraised at lower value
than a similar home owned by a white
family
and i might add and i need help if you
haven't answered this when i can't
figure this one out
congressman horsford but if you live in
a black community
and there's another one on the other
side of the highway it's a white
community it's just
built by the same builder and you have a
better driving record than the guy with
the same car
in the white community you're paying
more for your auto insurance
shockingly the percentage of black
american home ownership
is lower today in america
than when the fair housing act was
passed more than 50 years ago
lower today that's wrong
and we're committed to changing that
just imagine
he was said to deny millions of
americans the ability to own their own
home
and build generational wealth we made it
possible for them to buy a home and
build
equity into that into that home and
provide for their families
second small businesses are the engines
of our economy and the glue of our
communities
at as president my administration
oversees hundreds of billions of dollars
in federal contracts
for everything from refurbishing decks
of aircraft carriers and installing
railings in
federal buildings to professional
services
we have a thing called i won't go into
it at all there's not enough time now
but
i'm determined to use every taxpayer's
dollar that is assigned to me to spend
going to american companies and american
workers
to build that build american products
and as part of that
i'm going to increase the share of the
dollars the federal government spends
to small disadvantaged businesses
including black and brown small
businesses
right now it calls for 10 percent i'm
going to move that to 15
of every dollar spent on this bank
america
i have authority to do that
just imagine instead of denying millions
of entrepreneurs
the ability to access capital and and
contracting
made it possible to take their dreams to
the marketplace to create jobs and
invest in our communities that the data
shows
young black entrepreneurs are just as
capable of succeeding given the chance
as white entrepreneurs are
but they don't have lawyers they don't
have they
they don't have accountants but they
have great ideas
does anyone doubt this whole nation be
better off
from the investments those people make
and i promise you that's why i set up
this
national small business administration
that's much broader
because they're going to get those loans
instead of
consigning millions of american children
to under-resourced schools
let's get each and every child three and
four years old
access to school not day care school
in the last 10 years studies have been
done by all the great universities
it shows that are increased by 56
percent the possibility of a child no
matter what background they come from
no matter what if they start school at
three years old
they have a 56 chance of going all
through all 12 years
without any trouble and being able to do
well
and a chance to learn and grow and
thrive in a school
and throughout their lives and let's
unlock
more than an incredible creativity and
innovation that will come
from the nation's historically backed
colleges universities
you know i have a 5 billion a year
program giving them the resources to
invest
in research centers and laboratories and
high demand fields
to compete for good paying jobs in
industries like of the future like cyber
security
the reason why they don't their their
students are equally able to learn as
well
and get the good paying job to start at
90 and 100 000 bucks
but they don't have they don't have the
back they don't have the money
to provide and build those laboratories
so guess what
they're going to get the money to build
so those of just talking about
infrastructure what's good about
the uh about the business of actually
rebuilding roads and highways
filling the sidewalks and cracks
installing street lights and high-speed
internet
creating space space to live and work
and play safely
let's ensure access to healthcare clean
water clean air
nearby grocery stores stocked with fresh
vegetables and food that they in fact
deal with i mean
these are all things we can do does
anyone doubt
this whole nation will be better off
with these investments
the rich will be just as well off the
middle class will do better and
everybody will do better
it's about good paying jobs financial
stability
being able to build some generational
wealth it's about economic growth for
our
country and out competing the rest of
the world which is now
out competing us but just as fundamental
as any of these investments i've
discussed
this may be most fundamental the right
to vote right
[Applause]
a lot of the members of the black caucus
knew john lewis better night but i knew
him
on his deathbed like many i called john
to speak to him
forever all john wanted to do is talk
about how i was doing
he died i think about 25 hours later
but you know what john said he called
the right to vote precious
almost sacred he said the most powerful
non-violent tool we have in a democratic
society
this secret right is under assault with
incredible intensity like i've never
seen
even though i got started as a public
defender in a civil rights lawyer
with an intensity and aggressiveness
we've not seen in a long long time
it's simply unamerican it's not however
sadly unprecedented the creed
we shall overcome is a long time
mainstay of the civil rights movement
jesse jackson can tell you better than
anybody
the obstacle the process to progress
that have to be overcome are a constant
challenge
we saw in the 60s but with the current
assault
is not just an echo of a distant history
in 2020 we faced a tireless assault on
the right to vote
restrictive laws lawsuits threats to of
intimidation
voter purges and more we resolved to
overcome it all we did
more americans voted in the last
election than any in the midst of a
pandemic than any election
in american history
[Applause]
you got voters registered you got voters
to the polls
the rule of law held democracy prevailed
we overcame but today let me be
unequivocal
i've been engaged in this work my whole
career and we're going to be ramping up
our efforts to overcome
again i will have more to say about this
at a later date to truly
an assault on our democracy an effort to
replace nonpartisan election
administrators
and to intimidate those charged with
tallying and reporting the election
results
but today as for the act of voting
itself
i urge voting rights groups in this
country to begin to redouble their
efforts
now to register and educate voters and
in june
in june should be a month of action on
capitol hill
i hear all the folks on tv saying why
doesn't biden get this done
well because biden only has a majority
of effectively four votes in the house
and a
tie in the senate with two members of
the senate who vote
more with my republican friends
but we're not giving up earlier this
year the house of representatives passed
for the people act to protect our
democracy the senate
will take it up later this month and i'm
going to fight like heck
with every tool in my disposal for his
passage
the house is also working in the john
lewis voting rights act which is
which is critical to providing new legal
come back and you assault on the right
to vote
to signify the importance of our efforts
today i'm asking vice president harris
to help these efforts and lead them
among her many other responsibilities
with her leadership
and your support we're going to overcome
again i promise you
but it's going to take a hell of a lot
of work and
finally we have to
and finally we must address what remains
the stain
on the sole america what happened in
greenwood was an act of hate and
domestic terrorism
with the through line that exists today
still
just close your eyes remember what you
saw in charlottesville
four years ago on television neo-nazis
white supremacists the kkk
coming out of those fields at night
virginia with lighted torches
the veins bulging on their as they were
screaming remember just close your eyes
and picture what it was
well mother fletcher said when she saw
the insurrection at the capitol
on january the 9th it broke her heart
a mob of violent white extremists thugs
said reminded her of what happened here
in greenwood 100 years ago
look around the various hate crimes
against asian americans and jewish
americans
hate that never goes away hate only
hides
jesse i think i mentioned this to you i
thought after you guys
pushed through with dr king the voting
rights act and
the civil rights act i thought we were
moved
what i didn't realize i thought we made
enormous progress
i was so proud to be a little part of it
but you know what rav i didn't realize
hates never defeated it only hides
it hides and given a little bit of
oxygen
just a little bit of oxygen buys leaders
it comes out of there on from under the
rock like it was happening
again as if it never went away
so folks we can't we must not give hate
a safe harbor
as i said in my address the joint
session of congress according to the
intelligence community
terrorism from white supremacy is the
most
lethal threat to the homeland today not
isis not al qaeda white
supremacists that's not me
that's the intelligence community under
both
trump and under my administration two
weeks ago
i signed the law of the coven 19 hate
crimes act which the house had passed in
the senate
my administration will soon lay out our
broader strategy to counter domestic
terrorism
and the violence driven by the most
heinous hate crimes
and other forms of vigor of bigotry
but i'm going to close where i started
to mother randall
mother fletcher mr van ellis to the
descendants and to all
survivors thank you thank you for giving
me the honor of being able to spend some
time with you
earlier today thank you for your courage
thank you for your commitment and thank
your children
your grandchildren and your uncle and
your nieces and your nephews
to see and learn from you is a gift
a genuine gift dr john hope franklin
one of america's greatest historians
tulsa's proud son whose father was a
greenwood survivor said and i quote
whatever you do it must be done in the
spirit of good will and mutual respect
and even love
how else can we overcome the past
and be worthy of our forebearers and
face the future
comp with confidence and with hope
on this sacred and solemn day may we
find that distinctly greenwood spirit
that defines the american spirit
the spirit that gives me so much
confidence and hope for the future
that helps us see face to face a spirit
that helps us know fully who we are and
who we can be
as a people and as a nation
i've never been more optimistic about
the future than i am today
i mean that the reason is
because of this new generation of young
people
they're the best educated they're the
least prejudiced
the most open generation in american
history
and although i have no scientific basis
from what to say
but those of you who are over 50 how
often did you ever see
how often do you ever see advertisements
on television with black and white
couples
not a joke i challenge you
find today when you turn on the stations
sit on one station for two hours
and i don't know how many commercials
you'll see lay eight to five
two to three out of five have mixed-race
couples in them
that's not by accident they're selling
soap man
not a joke remember all pat goodell used
to say you want to know what's happened
in american culture
watch advertising because they want to
sell what they have
we have hope folks like you honey
i really mean it we have hope
but we've got to give them support we
have got to give them the backbone
to do what we know has to be done
because i doubt whether any of you would
be here if you didn't care
deeply about this you're sure the devil
didn't come to hear me speak
but i really mean it i really mean it
let's not give up man let's not give up
as old saying goes hope springs eternal
i know we've talked a lot about famous
people but i'm
uh my colleagues in the senate used to
always kid me because i was always
quoting irish poets
they think i did it because i'm irish
they think i did it because
we irish we have a little chip on our
shoulder a little bit sometimes
that's how i did it i did it because
they're the best posts in the world
you can smile it's okay it's true
there's a famous poet who wrote a poem
called the cure at troy
shame is he and there's a stanza that i
think
is the definition what i think should be
our call today for young people
he said history teaches us not to hope
on this side of the grave but then
once in a lifetime that long forward
tidal wave of justice rises up
and hope and history rhyme
let's make it right
so
um
[Music]
great
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
you